What is scripture and what his canon,
these are not necessarily the same thing.
When you call something scripture,
what you simply mean is it some kind
of writing that is taken by somebody as
holy and authoritative, somehow
sacred. Now different religions.
Some religions don't have what we would
normally think of the scripture and
Islam, Judaism or Christianity. They
might have lots and lots of holy writings,
but they don't have a particular
bounded body of writings that they call
scripture.
They have lots of inscribed in scripture.
What makes something scripture though is
that it's taken to be authoritative and
holy by some particular community.
Now that notice that does not necessarily
mean it's canonical because scripture
in some religions refers
to a bunch of stuff,
but they don't have a set list of
things that make something. The cannon,
Judaism, Islam, and Christianity
all have basically cannons. That is,
it's the Quran for Islam.
It's a the Hebrew Bible for Judaism
and it's the Hebrew Bible plus the New
Testament, and we'll talk about some of
the other writings too. For Christians.
What does it mean to cause something
Canon that makes it different from
scripture?
What by calling it Canon,
we're saying there's an actual list
that are religious body adheres to with
books that are either in
our books that are not in.
So scripture can refer to any kind of
writing that a bunch of people consider
holy or inspired or some
are authoritative. But when
you call something cannon,
you mean that there's a group of
writing that has boundaries to it.
And of course it just comes
from the Greek word Kennan,
spelled with one n not to
this Greek word means a list.
It can mean a Rod, a staff,
it can be a measuring rod.
And so it comes to be a list that
accounts as authoritative in early
Christianity. So that's what, um, that's
what it means to cost anything canonical.
When you talk about something
like the Shakespeare Canon,
the Canon of Shakespeare,
or the Canon of Great Western literature,
that's actually using the term in a bit
of an expanded sense because we don't
really consider Western literature
to have an actual closed canon of
authoritative text.
And Christianity though it means the
list of texts that are scripture and
recognized as different from other things.
We have to for first also recognize
that the early Christians,
it seems like from the very early period
at least a lot of them accepted Jewish
scripture as their own. So for
example, when the Apostle Paul says,
scripture says he's not talking
about the new testament.
He's talking about Jewish scripture.
So almost all the early Christians,
they didn't know that most of the people
writing the New Testament didn't know
they were writing the New Testament.
They just thought they were writing
a gospel or a sermon or a letter or
something like that.
So when you see the term scripture in the,
in the new testament all,
all every time,
except maybe one time we'll talk
about this when we get to it,
it refers to Jewish scripture
that Christians excepted,
followers of Jesus accepted as their own.
The oldest materials that
we have for Christianity.
And so I'd like to lecture today is going
to be about is how did the particular
27 books that came to be
the New Testament Canon,
how do those get chosen? By
whom? Who made the decision?
When did they make the decision and
what were the criteria that you used?
Why did they allow some books in and
other books not in the oldest written
materials of Christianity or
actually the letters of Paul.
This may come as a surprise because
you get to the gospels first in the New
Testament and most people assume, oh, the
gospels there about the life of Jesus.
That must be the oldest stuff with the
gospels were actually all written after
the letters of Paul were
written by 20 or 30 years.
So the oldest material we have or
the letters of Paul and the oldest,
one of those letters
is first Thessalonians
probably dated to around
the year 50 or thereabouts.
Pretty quickly though,
different churches,
probably Polish churches initially
started sending around copies of Paul's
letters. Remember there's no
printing press in the ancient world.
Whenever you have, whenever your church
would get a copy, when he says from Paul,
you would have scribes,
often slaves because slaves are
especially trained to be scribes.
They would take that letter and they would
make a copy of it and then they might
keep the original and they'd send
the copy off to somebody else.
So they might keep the copies
in the original offices meds.
And so letters would be copied in books
would be copied and sent around from
different communities. Communities.
This obviously happened um,
in Colassians for 16, which is actually,
I'll argue is not written by Paul,
although it claims to be written by Paul.
The writer says when this
letter has been read among you,
have it read also in the Church of the
layout of seasons and see that you read
also the letter from Laodicea.
So notice this author who I
think is a suit of pig refer.
He's riding in the name of Paul,
but not really Paul.
He's saying that there's another letter
sent by Paul to the layout of see in
church. So let them send
you their copy and use it.
And a copy of this letter to them.
So we quickly see that even in
the letters under Paul's name,
this activity's being spread around.
Also, we see the letter of Ephesians.
Again, claims to be by Paul,
but I'll argue is not by Paul.
When we get to the lecture
way into the semester,
the letter to the Ephesians looks like
it was not actually written to only one
church.
It looks like it was a circular letter
meant to be circulated to different
churches.
And one of the ways we think this one,
the reasons we think this because in
some of the old manuscripts of the law of
Ephesians to the Ephesians is not there.
It's either blank or it's
that to somebody else. So we,
some scholars have suggested that maybe
delay the Ephesians was originally
intended as a circular letter and maybe
the original writer sort of even left
some copies blank so that somebody
could fill in. Oh well let's see.
We're in Laodicea,
let's say to the loudest he ends and
we can act like Paul's and it just us.
So the manuscript tradition suggests
that it was a letter that was a circular
letter in itself.
We also have imitations of Paul's
letters developing. For example,
I said Collagen's I don't think is
written by Paul, by disciple of Paul.
Maybe after his death,
Ephesians was written by a different
disciple of Paul and he was using as his
model for appalling letter.
They actual letters of Paul that he,
or at least some of them
that he possessed new off,
but he was also using the letter to
the Collagen's. So notice this guy,
another guy sort of forging another letter
by Paul and he's using another Ford's
letter by Paul as his model that
the almost quotes than in places.
So we can tell that the writer of the
Ephesians seized have been a different
author, but he used the letter to
the Collagen's as one of his models.
So Paul's letters were being imitated,
new ones are being written and
they were being circulated.
Paul's letters actually became so famous
and respected and at least in some
aspects of early Christianity that
they were called themselves scripture.
And this is the one exception I said
to win. They win. In the New Testament.
You see the word scripture,
first of Jewish scripture,
the guy who wrote second Peter.
Again, not really Peter, uh,
but a rider riding and Peter's name talked
about Paul's letters as if any caused
them scripture.
He says there are many things in Paul's
that are very difficult to understand,
and some people twist them to their own
destruction as they do other kinds of
scripture. So already by the
time second Peter was written,
which was much later than the
lives of the letters of Paul,
Paul's letters have come to be regarded
by at least some early Christians as
scripture themselves.
So collections of Paul's letters were
gradually being made and copied and
circulate it. That's the first
development of what you have,
a collection of what would be
considered holy riding among Christians,
that it was more than just the Hebrew,
the Jewish scripture.
We also know though about, uh,
oral traditions in Paul's letters,
and this gets us back to how
do the gospels come about?
So the Paul's letters came about that way.
How did the gospels come about?
We know that they were oral
traditions about Jesus.
People would tell stories about
Jesus in their churches. Uh,
sometimes they would tell sayings.
So in Romans 1214,
Paul says,
bless those who persecute you.
Bless and do not curse them.
Now,
he doesn't say this is
a quotation of Jesus,
but it sounds an awful lot like
you find in some of the gospels,
like in Matthew five 44.
So Paul is saying this,
probably passing this along as a quotation
of Jesus in First Corinthians 1123
through 26 here,
I'll read this to you.
I wouldn't start bringing your Bible to
class if you haven't today because you
know, uh, you don't
know. You can't trust me.
And so you have to check me out and
make sure I'm not lying to you. Oh,
I should do this now perhaps because
it's the beginning of the semester,
the official motto of the class.
Yeah.
And you have to memorize this
day, Omni booths, doobie
tandem. Say it with me, please.
Day Omni booths to beat with
feeling day on about twice as loud.
Write it down.
Say it tonight before you go to sleep.
Say it in the morning when you
wake every day this semester.
Say it before we go to sleep.
Say it when you wake.
Can anybody tell me what it means?
Got It.
Doubt everything.
Okay,
and that includes me because I'm going
to lie to you a lot all semester long or
at least somebody would accuse
me of that, I guarantee. Okay?
First Corinthians 11 if you've got your
Bible, follow along with me. Verse 23
Okay
for I received from the Lord.
Paul says,
what I also handed on to you that the
Lord Jesus on the night when he was
betrayed, took a loaf of bread and when
he had given thanks, he broke it and said,
this is my body that is for you.
Do this in remembrance of me.
In the same way he took the
cup also after supper saying,
this Cup is the new covenant in my blood.
Do this as often as you drink it in
remembrance of me for as often as you eat
this bread and drink the cup, you
proclaim the Lord's death until he comes.
Where did Paul get this? He says, I gave
it to you as I was received at myself.
This is traditional Greek
language of passing on tradition.
So Paul knows he's passing
on a bit of tradition, very,
very early Christian tradition.
But Paul was not a disciple of
Jesus during Jesus' lifetime.
Paul never saw Jesus
except in his visions.
Paul saw Jesus in apocalyptic visions,
but he never saw Jesus a flesh and blood.
Uh,
and so Paul was not a disciple.
He must have gotten this from
other disciples of Jesus.
So what does this tell us?
This tells us that different disciples
of Jesus were remembering some of his
sayings and passing them around
to other people after his life,
uh, after. Now the first time. Uh,
well also there's another interesting
passage in First Corinthians nine 14 where
Paul says this in the same way the Lord
commanded that those who proclaim the
gospel should get their
living by the gospel. Now,
we actually don't have a saying in the
gospels that Jesus actually says that it
does sound a little bit like maybe
Luke chapter 10, verse seven.
But this is a saying that
Paul attributes to Jesus.
It's not actually in our gospels.
It also shows though,
it's interesting too that Paul says,
preachers should beit make their
living from preaching the Gospel.
That is churches should support uh,
the preachers and missionaries.
Paul says that's a command from Jesus.
He actually doesn't obey it though cause
he makes the point that himself is not
going to take money from
his churches at that point.
So the earliest gospel though that pulled
together some of these things that we
possess is the gospel of mark. It
probably was written around the year 70.
And in the next couple of lectures I'll
show you why we think we can pinpoint
around the date that the
gospel of Mark was written.
It's a very interesting little process.
Then the Matthew and Luke
were both written after and
they used mark as sources.
This is what, when you get
to the discussion section
on the synoptic problem,
which is your first discussion section,
you'll learn all this theory about
the relationship between Matthew,
mark and Luke, who was written first,
who copied, whom, who used whom.
And that sort of thing. The beginning
of Luke though starts off like this.
Since many have undertaken to set down
an orderly account of the events that
have been fulfilled among us,
just as they were handed onto us by
those who from the beginning were eye
witnesses and servants of the word.
I too decided after
investigating everything
carefully from the very first to
write an orderly account for you,
most excellent Theopolis so that you
may know the truth concerning the things
about what you have been instructed.
Now what does that tell us?
That tells us that this, whoever
wrote the gospel of Luke, and again,
I'll tell you that it wasn't
the historical person called
Luke who's a companion
of Paul probably, but whoever wrote
this says that he did some research,
he collected other sayings about Jesus.
He even looked at other written accounts
and from those different things,
he himself compiled his own gospel.
So we can tell that the gospel
is start off with oral tradition.
It's being passed around different
sayings and stories about Jesus.
And then gradually, uh, but only about
40 years after the death of Jesus,
the gospel of Mark is in the year 70.
If Jesus was crucified around near 30,
that's a 40 year period of time between
the death of Jesus and the appearance of
the First Gospel that we possess.
Although there were other written
materials being pastor under at that time.
Now what does this say about this?
Um,
some of this we tend to think as modern
people that a written text is actually
the best thing.
It's better than just rumor
or hearsay or oral tradition.
It's interesting though that some ancient
people didn't think that. In fact,
there's a guy named [inaudible],
he's on your handout.
He was a Christian leader who lived,
probably wrote about some of this stuff
in around the year one 30 or one 40.
And he says this about
his own little research.
I shall not hesitate to put down for
you with my interpretations whatsoever.
Things I well learned at one time from
the presbyters just meaning the old
people,
old guys,
elders and well remembered confidently
asserting truthfulness for them.
For I did not take pleasure
as the multitude does in
those who say many things,
but in those who teach
the things that are true,
nor did I take pleasure in those
who recall strange commands,
but in those who recall the commands
given by the Lord to the faith and coming
from truth itself.
But if per chance there came also
anyone who had followed the presbyters,
the elders,
I made inquiry concerning the words or
the presbyters what Andrew or what Peter
had said,
oh,
what Philip or Thomas or James or what
John or Matthew or any of the other
disciples of the Lord said, and what
things are STN and the presbytery,
John Disciples of the Lord
used to say for I did not.
Suppose if the things from the books
would aid me so much as things from the
living and continuing voice. Notice
what paper says he's doing. He,
he's not,
he doesn't interview the actual apostles.
He's too long after their death,
but he tries to find people who are old
men who knew the apostles and he tried.
He says he questioned them about
what they said. Jesus had said.
That's interesting because it
shows this continuing tradition,
but it's also interesting in he says he
trusted that traditional living voice
more than he trusted written documents,
so that's important to keep in mind.
The next time we see some development
in how this new testaments was coming
about is around the middle
of the second century.
We have a guy named Justin martyr,
he we,
he's called that because he was martyred
for the faith around the year one 50 he
mentions the memoirs of the apostles.
We think he's probably
talking about the gospels,
but he doesn't actually use that term
as much as he talks about the memoirs of
the apostles, so he knows that
there's written documents.
We also know that around this time
there are several different things being
passed around that looked like gospels.
There's Matthew, mark, Luke, and John,
which are in our Bible,
but there's also the gospel of Thomas
that we know about very early on.
And then we,
we,
you've heard the news about the gospel
of Judas being discovered recently and
published. So there's,
there's a gospel of Mary.
There are several other gospels that are
floating around in the second century.
So that's how these written
documents come about.
How did they settle on these four
though first then you have to,
we have to talk about Marcien. I think
he's on your handout, is that correct?
Yes.
Marcien who died around one 60
Martian was this guy from Asia minor,
modern day Turkey,
and just get used to that term because
whenever we say Asia minor were talking
about that section around the
Mediterranean that now is called Turkey,
but it was called Asia minor generally
in the Roman imperial period.
Martian came to Rome from Asia Minor.
He seemed to be a successful man.
His ship builder. He gave the Roman
church a huge sum of money and as,
and so he got a lot of honor,
but then he started teaching some,
some doctrines that struck
other Christians in Rome
as being a little bit off.
For one thing, Marcien said that
the, the God who's mentioned in that,
in the Jewish scripture,
the God who created the earth is
not the father of Jesus Christ.
He's a bungling or evil or bad God.
He gave all these people these
bad rules and he'd pinch,
punish them if they didn't obey the rules.
That's not the God that Jesus talked
about as being the God of grace and love
and mercy. So he said that God is
not the the father of Jesus Christ.
That's not the god that
Jesus was talking about.
So what we need to do is throw
away Jewish scripture. So he said,
we Christians don't need Jewish scripture.
That's all about a wrong God. Anyway,
it's about a false god. We don't need
that. What we need, he said is the Gospel.
And in fact, he chose one of these
gospels. He took the gospel of Luke.
Why did hit the gospel of Luke?
Because he believed Luke
had been a companion of Paul
and Luke correctly passed
on Paul's Gospel because Paul
was Martians, fave, fave,
apostle,
marching,
believe that Paul had been the only one
of the different apostles who got it
right because he taught people you don't
have to obey the Jewish law. In fact,
he taught people you
shouldn't obey the Jewish law.
So Marcien said Paul got it right.
He threw out the Old Testament.
He threw out the Jewish God and he
introduced the correct gospel of Jesus and
Luke Record that in his gospel. So
Marcien said the only thing that could be,
should be scripted for us is not a
Jewish scripture. Get rid of that.
We just need the 10 letters
of Paul that he knew about.
Now there are actually 13 letters of
Paul that claim to be like by Paul in our
Bible.
Marcien seem to know only 10 of them.
That might be interesting
later on in the semester too,
but he seemed to only include 10 letters
in his list and then the 10 letters of
Paul and Luke.
Now,
you may have noticed if you've actually
read any of the letters of Paul and the
gospel of Luke,
that these people seem to blend,
believe that the creator God mentioned
in Jewish scripture actually was the
father of Jesus Christ marching and
noticed some of those places too.
Or like when Paul Singh be quoting
Jewish scripture. So Marcien said, Aha.
The other Jewish apostles,
the bad apostles got hold of Paul's
letters and they got hold of the Gospel of
Luke and they adulterated.
They put all this other stuff in,
so loose marching claimed that he could
edit out all the added stuff out of
Paul's letters and of the gospel of Luke
and this edited version of the gospel
of Luke and the 10 letters of Paul.
That's what and published as his cannon.
He was,
this is the first time
we have in Christianity,
someone attempting to say this is the
authoritative list and all these other
things are not part of the list.
Marcion who came to be considered
a heretic by Orthodox Christians.
Remember that at this time, there's a
lot of different kinds of Christianity.
So how do you tell an Orthodox Christian
from an heretical Christian? Well,
it's your judgment.
Call her mind in the second century,
you hadn't had yet the creeds that would
try to settle these things for good
like you did in the third and
fourth century, the fourth century,
but a lot of Christians in Rome,
the Bishop of Rome,
a lot of other people considered
Marty and a heretic for this.
They kicked him out of the church that
gave him back his money that he could
give him to the church,
and they kicked him out and
they declared this is heretical.
The creator God really is God. The Jewish
scripture really is our scripture. Uh,
and the Jewish God is really the god
of Israel, is the God of Jesus Christ.
Also the father, Jesus Christ. But
Marcien seems to really put the scare,
but Jesus into the Roman church.
If you didn't have,
if you didn't accept
Martians Canon his list,
what was going to be your list if you
said that the other gospels were just as
much,
just as important as the gospel of Luke
who said so and why and who's going to
pronounce this Marcien though seem to
have spurred other Christian leaders to
decide what they thought, um,
Christian scripture should do.
So what do you do about the gospels?
You have four different gospels
excepted by some people,
five or six by other people
generally in roam around this time,
the four gospels that we have in our
Bible seem to become the most popular
excepted gospels, Matthew,
mark, Luke, and John. Now,
some people still try to figure out that
you've got four. Why do you have for,
so you have other people like [inaudible].
He's on your handout list too.
He decided to take the four gospels and
do an addition that would string all the
stuff from the different
four gospels into one book.
So he made what we call the dia tests are,
which is a Greek word.
It means through four. He took four
books and created one gospel out of it.
You had other people
who said, well, um, uh,
you accept the gospel of mark because
mark was a disciple of Peter. Uh,
this is the way papists
believed elsewhere.
He said that mark had traveled
with rum tote with Peter to Rome,
and mark wrote down Peter's version
of the Gospel and that's, and so pay.
Pia said, that's why mark is a
reliable, or people would say,
Luke wrote down the gospel that Paul
had preached. So Luke was authoritative.
They also say, well, Matthew
was actually one of the apostle,
one of the disciples of Jesus. He's
mentioned in the Gospel. So He, he,
the gospel of Matthew
is also by a good one.
And John also was believed to be that.
Now the problem with this
is that paperless and these
other people didn't really
know what they were talking about.
Papists for example,
thought that the gospel of Matthew had
originally been written in Hebrew and
only later translated into Greek.
This is wrong.
Any of us who know Greek and no Hebrew
can tell that the gospel of Matthew was
written in Greek. It doesn't look
like a translation from Hebrew,
so we tend to doubt all of
these different traditions.
That mark was the disciple of
Peter who wrote Peter's Gospel,
that Matthew was written by
the actual disciple Matthew,
that Luke was written by the disciple
of Paul and that John was written by the
the disciple John.
Basically what modern scholars believe
is that all four of these gospels were
anonymously published.
They don't tell us who their author is.
They notice they don't.
They're not pseudonymous.
There's a difference between suited suited
pseudonomas writing's easy for me to
say.
Yeah,
and anonymous.
Anonymous means we
don't know who wrote it.
It's published without an
author's name being listed.
Pseudonymous means it's
published with a false name,
a false author attributed the got the
four gospels are not pseudonymous because
the earliest manuscripts of these gospels
we believe did not contain the titles
Gospel of Mathew Gospel of Mark Gospel,
the gospel of John.
They just published the
text as it was at least we,
if it ever did have an
author's name attached to it.
We don't have any evidence
in the manuscript history
nor we have any evidence in
any other, uh, historical place.
What happened was these names
got attached to these documents
and that's eventually how they
got included into the cannon.
People thought that these
documents eventually were
written by the people whose
names that they possess and therefore
they thought they had some kind of
connection to the apostles.
Notice.
What's your,
the Canon list eventually being a have I,
this is on your handout also.
Look at the mirror. Torian Canon.
This is,
I remember the word Canon just means list,
so this was a list of books that some
author believed where scripture and should
be read by Christians and churches and
he mentions others that he believes they
should not. Sometimes he didn't
believe they were bad books.
He sometimes he believes they just
weren't supposed to be included with the
highest canonical books.
There's a big debate about whether this
Canon list was composed around the year
200 or are around the year 400 scholars
tend to line up one side of the other.
It used to be when I was in Grad
school that most people said, oh,
it was written around the year 200 now
I understand that probably the majority
of scholars who say, no, it
comes from a later period.
That's not really all important for us
because what's important for us to see at
this point, uh, either 200 to 400
what was included, what was not.
This Canon list,
uh,
includes these books that aren't in
our Bible. The wisdom of Solomon,
which is actually in the Apocrypha and
I'll talk about that and the apocalypse
of Peter. We do have an apocalypse of
Peter along with the apocalypse of John.
It's just not in our Bible.
It's considered new testament
apocryphal writings.
They also, this rider excluded
these books that are in our Bible.
The letter to the Hebrews.
One letter of John.
He rejects the shepherd of Hermas,
which was is a book that we
include in groupings of Ryan.
We call the epistatic fathers.
It was written in the second century
sometime by a guy in Rome named Hermis and
it's called the shepherd and
he, he excludes other books.
He calls gnostic books.
We'll talk later in the semester about
what does gnostic mean at this time.
So notice that this is,
this could be a very early can
enlist and it doesn't match our list.
It does have the four gospels though.
Then the first time you get a list by
any Christian that we serve that we still
possessed.
It's extent that survives.
That has the 27 books of the New Testament
that is in our Bible is in the year
367 it's an Easter letter by the Bishop
Athanasius who is bishop of Alexandria
bishops at this time,
especially a major cities would sometimes
send around what we call a pastoral
letter and Easter letter in which they
get instructions are different kinds of
things to their churches and in one year
when he's doing this he says these are
the books that you should
read and should not read.
And this is the first time that the
precise 20 books that he lists are the 27
books that we list.
It's interesting though,
he does list the letters of Paul last
but behind the other letters rather than
before them as we have in our list.
And then we don't really start getting
any kind of consistency with this until
into the third and fourth and
fifth and sixth centuries.
So on I'm saying now is it took a long
time for this to solidify and one of the
things we think made it solidify was
the development of codices a codex.
What is a codex?
Early books were all scrolls,
so you might have a book if he had a book,
as long as the gospel of Matthew,
it'd take up a pretty thick scroll.
Now, what happens if you want to read,
not the whole book of Matthew, but you
should want to read Matthew 1313 will.
You have to unroll your scroll. You're run
row, row, row, row, row, row, row, row.
You have to find the place
and they roll it all back up.
And what happens if you want to move back
and forth between a bunch of different
letters? Well, you have to
unroll different scrolls
scrolls. And in synagogues,
they didn't have books like this.
They just had a basket or a box or a
place called uneasy and they just had
scrolls all in it.
So if you wanted to read Isaiah,
it actually was more than one scroll,
so you'd have to take that
scroll out and undo it.
Now what some scholars may have have
speculated, we don't know this for sure,
sometime around this period of
time when early Christianity,
if somebody got the big idea,
hey,
let's cut up the scroll into pages and
so the pages together and then put it all
in a book, and that way you can
flip around and it a lot easier.
Some scholars have even speculated that
Christians may be the first to do this
because they were arguing with their
friends. The Jews are their enemies,
the Jews in some cases,
and if you want to prove that
Jesus really was born of a virgin,
well you need to go to that passage in
Isaiah where at least the Greek version,
it's not in the Hebrew,
but the Greek version of the Jewish
scripture said that a woman would be born,
this man would be born of a virgin.
That's the prophecy that we read around
Christmas time. A virgin will bear a son,
but you might have to also refer to a
psalm over here or to another patch is
over here and it's too difficult if
you're unraveling scrolls and everything.
So some people believe that Christians
precisely because they wanted to proof
text a lot. They wanted to run around
through a lot of different texts.
They actually invented the Codex.
I'm not talking about tampons.
Code decks with an e.
Okay.
All that means is this is a codex.
It just means pages sewn together and
placed within the covers of a book.
So what we call, when you see the
word book in ancient Greek or Latin,
they didn't think of this.
They thought of scrolls.
So when you see where book there,
the mechanical thing they're
actually talking about is a scroll.
This was an interesting new invention
of a new piece of technology.
Maybe not quite as
revolutionary as the computer,
but clothes because all of
a sudden cumbersome scrolls.
This would what's would be
contained in the code of CS.
We have the plural of this is
either codex is sometimes our,
if you want to act like you
actually know Greek, I mean Latin,
you'd use the old Latin plural codices.
You'll see both of those
written in different sources.
A Codex of the Bible
would be pretty big bay,
that thick and that why
that some the ones we have,
we have there are stored
in the Vatican museum.
We have a few of them that
survive from this period.
They're pretty impressive looking.
Uh,
but there'd be big but still that would
be a lot easier to transport and handle
than a whole box or
closet full of scrolls.
So this was a very innovative
piece of technology.
But one problem with it, this also
caused is if you're going to put all the,
the books,
the documents that you think are scripture
between two covers and not just have
a bunch of scrolls lying in a
box or a closet with the scrolls.
You can take one out and put another in.
If you decide that you think
Daniel is not scripture,
do you think the revelation of John, not
scripture, just take it out of the box,
put it somewhere else in the,
in the synagogue or the church.
But once you start publishing
things in between covers,
you actually have to decide
what goes in and what goes out.
And so around this time, the
third, fourth, and fifth century,
we get different codices different codex
is that his books and they will and we
can tell them what sorts of books
they included in their scripture.
And notice on your handout,
just some examples of this,
the Canon of Momsen early Fourth
Century Canon includes Matthew,
mark, John, and Luke in
that order. So it has,
there are four and only are
four but in a different order.
It excludes the letter to the Hebrews,
the letter of James, letter of Jude,
and it argues,
this is one the interesting thing about
it argues that the books must be exactly
24 because revelation four 10 has 24
elders in God's throne room convincing
argument,
right?
A Codex Sa Synetic Skus,
which is around the year three 50 we
think this is one of the earliest codices
of the Bible we have,
it includes the letter of Barnabas,
which we don't have in our bibles,
but we do possess it.
And the shepherd of Hermas,
which I already talked about,
which was written somewhere
around the year 100 and Rome,
or after the right after that,
it also excludes Jude.
So it has two books that we don't include
and exclude one that we do include
codex, Claremont, tennis
from the sixth century.
So in the five hundreds
includes Matthew, John, mark,
and Luke again has all four
of us in a different order.
It has led her a Barnabas, the sheep,
the shepherd of Hermas, the acts of Paul,
not the, uh, along with the acts of the
apostles and the revelation of Peter.
So it has that revelation of Peter.
Again,
it excludes Paul's letter to the
Philippians, which is in our Bible,
Hebrews and first and
second Thessalonians.
Now notice this means that some people
would say that they use that three 67
date when bishop Athanasius send around
his Easter litter and they say that's
when the Christian Canon of
the New Testament was set
because it's the earliest
as we have. But that's not
really right. That was just,
he was just bishop of one city,
one area.
His letter was not binding on anybody
else except the churches in his
Alexandrian diocese.
So it didn't set the cannon three 67
is simply the time when we'd get the
earliest list that matches our list
of 27 books in the New Testament.
But you can see when you look at
all these different code disease,
different Canon list from a century
later in the four hundreds two centuries
later in the five hundreds three centuries
later in the six hundreds you still
get different lists.
So there was,
it took a long time for the 27 books that
we have to get settled on and it was,
and we'll talk about how that
actually happened. Also still
wear what really happened was consensus.
Different bishops in different major
cities and different councils would
sometimes try to decide
and they'd put out decrees,
but they never completely settled the
question for all Christians everywhere
around the world.
This is surprising,
but what counts as the Bible is still
not agreed upon by Christians around the
world. So generally the
Canon of the New Testament,
our 27 books is accepted by all
Christian churches generally,
except that the revelation of John is
still not part of the lectionary or Canon
in some eastern and Middle Eastern
churches. So for example, if you,
I can't remember which
of these, uh, there are,
but there are churches all through
the Middle East in the east also,
and some of them don't have the
revelation of John in the New Testament.
The Canon of all of scripture therefore
has never been completely the same for
all Christians everywhere.
The western Roman Catholic Canon
and the Greek Slavonic bibles have,
for example,
Tobit part of the Old Testament Judith,
the wisdom of Solomon
Ecclesiasticus Baruch and the
letter of Jeremiah and first
and second Maccabees.
They also have a longer version of
Daniel and a longer version of Esther.
So if you, the western Roman Catholic
Canon and Greek and Slavonic bibles,
we'll include our canon that
we have that you have probably,
but they'll also maybe include things that
if you grew up in a Protestant church,
was not in your Protestant Bible.
The Greek and Slavonic.
Bible's also accept first as
dress the prayer of Manasseh.
Psalm one 51 they have another
song and third Maccabees,
another Maccabean book.
You don't need to memorize all this is,
I'm just trying to give you an idea
of the variety of different canons for
different churches in different regions.
The Slavonic and Latin vulgate also accept
psalm one 51 and third Maccabees and
the Greek cannon also
accepts fourth Macka B's.
Why is the Protestant Canon like it is?
Well,
at the time of the reformation,
Roman Catholics had not only the 27 books
of the New Testament Canon that we now
have and they had what Protestants
came to accept as the Old Testament,
but they had several other books that
we now call the Apocrypha such as Judith
Tobit or the Maccabee first and second
Maccabees. When you buy your Bible,
if you buy the one I ordered,
it's called the new Oxford annotated
Bible with Apocrypha. And they take these,
they certain books and they put them in
a special section of the Bible to show
that they're not exactly
part of the Hebrew Bible,
but they're also not part
of the New Testament.
But early Christians
accepted all these books.
Early Christians didn't read
the Hebrew Bible in Hebrew.
They all read it in Greek.
So when they were first
dealing with Jewish scripture,
they didn't read it in the Hebrew.
They read it in Greek, Greek.
There were several other Greek Jewish
documents that weren't part of the
traditional Hebrew Bible, but they
were still accepted by a lot of Jews.
And therefore by a lot of
Christians as scripture,
those books were accepted by Catholics,
by Roman Catholics,
and by Christians up until the reformation
at the reformation, the reformers,
Martin Luther, Calvin, uh, my lengthen,
they decided that this was member of the,
the after the renaissance
and the beginnings of the
enlightenment and not the
enlightenment,
but the renaissance and,
and the rediscovery of the
study of Greek and Latin texts.
In the original documents,
they want to go back to the Hebrew.
So they learned Hebrew. They started
reading the Hebrew Bible in Hebrew,
not in Greek or Latin translation.
They also tried to come up with the
correct Greek text of the New Testament
documents by doing textual criticism.
They were practicing what was burgeoning
scholarship of the period in the 16th
century to go back to the original
texts as close as they could get.
What these reformers then
did, they said, wait a minute,
look at all these Greek Jewish books
that aren't part of the Hebrew Bible.
They don't exist in Hebrew. They
only exist in Greek. So they said,
we're not going to accept those
as part of the Old Testament.
They decided to go back to what,
uh,
the Hebrew texts of the Old Testament and
not accept the Greek Jewish documents.
The Roman Catholics decided, no, we're
going to keep these documents also,
which is why the Roman
Catholic Old Testament is
larger than the Protestant Old
Testament.
The Roman Catholic Old Testament has
the same books that the Protestant Old
Testament has,
but they kept these other Greek
Jewish documents and we call those the
Apocrypha. The hidden writings
just is what it means. Yes, sir.
The Jewish Bible started developing
when in the rabbinic period.
So what the rabbis, and then this
is all after Jesus and Paul's,
we're talking about the third, fourth, and
fifth and sixth centuries. They started,
uh,
teaching people that only the Hebrew
scriptures in Hebrew should be used.
In other words,
that the rabbis eventually
started rejecting the use
of the Greek Bible. Also,
this took time though,
because at the time of Paul and Jesus,
more Jews actually had Greek
as their first language,
then had Hebrew as their first language.
Most Jews in the first century would've
used Greek as their first language,
not Hebrew, or even Aramaic. So
they read their scripture in Greek.
What happened was, and some people would
believe this is a debated question,
I would even say that one reason the
rabbi's started using Hebrew more with
precisely and taking the Hebrew Bible is
because they were reacting against the
predominance of Christianity as
it grew and more and more strong.
So as rabbinic ideas and as rabbinic
practices developed in late antiquity,
they taught that they should reject the
Greek Bible, not use the Greek Bible,
except you know, you could use it,
but not use it as authoritative.
And they started teaching that the
Hebrew Bible should be the ones Jews use.
So the Jews today where
they call it [inaudible],
which is an acronym from Torah, and
then profit, the, the Torah, the law,
the prophets,
and the writings so that they will call
their Bible to knock often or just the
Bible.
And it includes only those Hebrew
documents that the rabbis eventually said,
we're part of the Hebrew Bible.
Good question.
So notice how Jews have one bible
that's basically centered on the ancient
Hebrew.
Protestants have followed the rabbis in
a sense and accepted the Hebrew Bible as
being the Old Testament Roman Catholics
actually followed more what was ancient
Christian tradition of accepting
not only the Hebrew Bible,
although it was translated into
Latin and Greek most of the time,
but also Jewish documents
that came from that period.
And we're surviving in Greek itself.
So that's why Christian Protestants
have one tech, a set of text.
Robin cabinets have another
and Jews have another.
Now what about those Episcopalians?
As one of my friends says
those whiskey Balian's,
they decided to be in the middle.
So they want the somewhat
Protestant and somewhat Catholic.
So if you go to an Anglican church,
they will also,
most of the time except the
Roman Catholic Canon, uh,
along with Roman Catholics, even though
a lot of Episcopalians Anglicans,
a lot of them, not all of them will
consider themselves Protestants.
So Anglicans follow the Roman
Catholic candidate a bit more.
Protestants and Jews have different ones.
That's kind of where we are right now.
But notice how long it took us to get
there, how many centuries it took. Now,
the big question is who did
it and why did they do it?
Basically some councils in the early
church councils to be called by the of,
by Constantine or his successors.
Sometimes they would get so
tired of churches, you know,
you know how Christians
squabble all the time. You know,
when I was a kid growing up in Texas,
one of our sayings was let's make
like a baptist and split like,
like a Baptist church and
split. So tr, you know,
Christians are always squabbling.
So councils would try,
the emperors would try to call and get
the councils to get them to agree on
things, to get them to agree on doctrine,
to get them to do, to agree on the Canon.
So some councils did try to set the
cannon and so you had some councils doing
this, but generally the
cannon developed over time,
through a process of general consensus.
And then as I said,
through these different institutions
of Christianity ending up coming to
somewhat different decisions,
but why do they include things?
Why were some texts included in the new
testament and other techs not including
the New Testament?
The reason is not the one that most
modern people think is the reason most
people today is why is this
text scripture? Why is it Canon?
And most Christian will say,
because it is inspired.
That's not what the ancients believed.
They believed that inspiration.
There were lots of texts that were
inspired and there are different levels of
inspiration. So just because
of text is inspired, uh, even,
even if you believe it's inspired
by God and that God told my variety,
that wasn't enough for ancient
Christians to include it in their Bible,
in their cannon.
So inspiration,
contrary to modern assumptions was not
the criteria you hear ancient people talk
about. Epistolic of authorship
was one thing they talk about.
So for example, pape IOUs and other
ancient writers, they said, well,
we accept the gospel of mark because well,
if it wasn't written by an apostle,
it was written by someone
very close to an apostle.
And it was Peter's Gospel
that mark just published,
or Luke published Paul's Gospel.
Now.
And so often some people
in the ancient world,
if there was a gospel they didn't like,
they didn't want it to be included.
They would argue against it
being authored by an apostle,
so that at least they claimed for some
that through these texts that they wanted
at the static authorship or
close to episodic authorship.
The problem was we can tell historically
that these texts were not written by
apostles,
nor do we believe they were written even
by the closest disciples of apostles.
They're anonymous texts.
So if that was the reason they were
included in the ancient world, uh,
it is not the reason they're still in
now because modern scholars don't believe
the apostles actually wrote all of
these texts in the new testament
flexibly.
Here are the criteria.
If it's not necessarily a puzzle
ship and it's not inspiration,
what are the real reasons?
First,
it seems that the texts that at least
these people believed were the most
ancient and had the closest
proximity to Jesus. Like I said,
they wanted them to be
traced back to the apostles.
So even if they weren't is because that's
what people believed about these texts.
A second big reason was
simply general acceptance.
Apparently the texts that were the most
popular over a bigger geographical space
tended to be the ones that got
in. Now, there were, it's true,
there were different gospels that
were popular in different parts of the
Mediterranean,
so for example,
the gospel of Thomas seems to have been
especially popular in certain parts of
the east and in and Rome.
There'd be other document or
different parts of the Roman empire,
but generally as timeline on it seems
like Christian leaders tried to include
those gospels, those documents that
were more generally accepted. In fact,
if you wanted to argue against,
say the letter of Hebrews being included,
you could,
you could say,
but all the people in the east don't
accept the letter of Hebrews as part of
their canon, so we shouldn't either.
So general acceptance was a big,
but the most important criterion
is probably won't shock you,
especially if you're a cynical as I am
theological acceptibility people tended
to want to include the documents
that matched their own theology.
In other words,
you believe something was epistolic
if it taught stuff you believed.
So of course documents that did teach
that the creator God was an evil demonic
God and not the father of Jesus Christ.
And there were,
there are early Christian documents
that teach this. They were excluded.
Why were they excluded? Well, some
of them claim to be by apostles.
Nobody exactly knew how old they were.
They were excluded because they taught
a doctrine that other Christians thought
was heretical and not accurate.
So when you say though theological
appropriateness is what ended up being the
most important criteria for
including stuff in the Canon,
you actually have to say
then appropriate to whom?
And of course that means
you have a judgment call.
But generally the documents
that came to be accepted,
and we're the ones that people
we call the pro tow orthodox.
This is a term that Bart
Erhman uses in his textbook.
You'll see it and he explains
what he means by this. In
the second century, it's,
you can't really use the term
Orthodox Christianity versus heretical
Christianity because there wasn't
orthodox, he hadn't been established yet.
It was all in a state of flux. The people
believed all kinds of different things.
And what are these classes we'll
do is talk about how did Orthodox,
what came Orthodox Christianity,
how did it become Orthodox Christianity
rather than than one of the other kinds
of Christianity.
And we'll talk about that repeatedly
in the second century though,
it's an it's anachronistic to talk about
Orthodox Christianity versus heretical
Christianity.
So what some scholars have done is
create this word pro tow orthodox,
and all they mean is those Christians
who believe the kinds of stuff that would
later be proclaimed as orthodox
and creeds and councils.
So what happens was the people who are
the Christians in the second century and
the third century who resembled
what later became Nice Ian Orthodox
Christianity,
they were the ones who had the most say
eventually in what became part of the
Bible.
So in the end,
the Canon is a list of the winners in
the historical debate to define Orthodox
Christianity questions,
comments, outburst, rantings and ravings.
Nope.
Yes sir.
Fulfilled.
How would the name tag on,
okay.
If the books were written anonymously,
how did the names that
are associated with them?
Other fields where we've done that,
we read a book
that would sound metal up
what we think so and so, yeah,
the most of the stuff that we'll say
has a wrong name attached in the new
testament is not anonymous,
although there are songs,
it's pseudonymous but there are some
that are anonymous to the gospels.
We'd say are anonymous because they
didn't come attached with a name as far as
we know. Um, how did those names get
attached by different people at parties?
Because they wanted this
text to be authoritative in
some way and so they tended
to attach the name of a particular apostle
to them are particular disciple art.
In some ways. For example, the Gut,
the gospel of Luke may have gotten his
name Luke because in the acts of the
apostles,
which is also written by the same author,
Luc is an actual character
who follows Paul around.
So it may have been that the name Luke
in acts of the apostles got connected
with the acts of the Apostles and
the gospel of Luke as its author.
So sometimes it's as something in the
text itself that may have prompted someone
to think that often we just
don't know how it got in.
It just happened because somebody
has said it's authoritative.
It must have been written by an apostle.
We have time for one more question.
I think I saw a hand up then we need
to dismiss no more questions. Okay.
See you next time.
Remember we are meeting on Friday.